[Musique]
il y à plus d'un an
emmanuel macron lançait le grand débat
national en réponse à la crise dès gilet
jaune à l'issue duquel est annoncé la
création d'une convention citoyenne pour
le climat aujourd'hui dans notre
démocratie on n'inclut pas suffisamment
nos concitoyens et l'idée la démarche de
la convention citoyenne c'est ça c'est
de dire les concitoyens ont demandé plus
de démocratie parce qu'ils ne veulent
pas simplement être celles et ceux qui
respectent des lois même si elles sont
faites par leurs représentants mais ils
veulent maintenant participer à
l'élaboration ses droits un exercice de
démocratie délibérative inédit avec 150
citoyens tirés au sort parmi 250 mille
numéros de téléphone une sorte de france
en miniature
vous avez été tiré au sort et donc il y
à tous les âges tous les faits que
toutes les orientations politiques
ils ont travaillé pendant neuf mois pour
proposer des mesures contre le
réchauffement climatique
le chef de l'état s'est engagé à les
transmettre sans filtre à référendum ou
au vote du parlement
le système économique incitant à
produire et à consommer toujours plus
est il compatible avec la transition
écologique
on souhaite les jeunes s'investir
davantage dans la question écologique
nous citoyens nous souhaitons que nos
travaux servent d'accélérateur de la
prise de conscience d'un futur
climatiques qui s'annoncent difficiles
et l'action prendrez vous pour faire en
sorte que nos travaux soient pleinement
connu et reconnu par l'ensemble des
français
nous avons suivi trois des citoyens
tirés au sort comment ont-ils vécu cette
expérience
cette convention peut-elle préfigurer
une nouvelle forme de démocratie
[Musique]
le train vient de quitter nantes
direction paris williams seront à la
convention citoyenne pour un week end
entier de travail quand il a été appelé
pour y participer
ce père de famille de 33 ans a d'abord
cru à une arnaque publicitaires il a
voulu vérifier de quoi il s'agissait
avant de donner suite et j'avais une
peur ce qui me rappelle plus en fait à
un moment je suis urbaniste
il a toujours été sensible aux questions
climatiques repensant petit à petit son
quotidien pour réduire son empreinte
carbone
très souvent on y pense on aimerait que
les choses changent très souvent on
pense que le mode de vie dans lequel on
est et qu'on a choisi et ben serait
tellement bien s'ils étaient partagés
alors avec la convention
il espère sensibiliser le plus grand
nombre la possibilité dans une vie en
tant que simple citoyen de faire quelque
chose donc voila c'était ça qui est
c'est ça qui a motivé à mon oui
catégorique
c'est en plein coeur du 16e
arrondissement de paris au conseil
économique social et environnemental
le cee troisième chambre de la
république que williams et les autres
membres de la convention ont travaillé
lors des sessions mensuelles répartis en
groupes thématiques pour rédiger leurs
mesures
un peu à l'image des commissions
parlementaires le hasard du tirage au
sort a voulu que william fasse partie du
groupe seloger c'est celui que nous
avons suivi les amis on s'y met y les
deux heures 24 des professionnels du
dialogue citoyen encadre les échanges
pour permettre à chacun de s'exprimer
dans de bonnes conditions
ce matin l'essentiel c'est que vous
précisiez l'intitulé de la mesure et les
objectifs poursuivis
à quoi elle va servir toutes les mesures
proposées doivent répondre à un objectif
réduire les émissions de co2 de 40%
d'ici 2030
c'est le monde a donné par l'exécutif
impacts possibles de la mesure sur la
création des solutions qu'on assemble
d'emploi impact potentiellement négatif
sur certaines zones le potentiel de
développement économique a freiné
beaucoup découvrent que le bâtiment est
l'un des plus gros émetteurs de gaz à
effet de serre penser la ville et
l'habitat de demain une réflexion où
chacun apporte ses connaissances son
expérience personnelle
ils font verront quoi oui heureusement
qui sera moi je suis en bretagne
c'est un leurre c'est un gâchis d'argent
public
je pense que le constat vous l'avez tous
les freins en tout cas dont il faut se
forcer je sais que c'est dur et on aime
beaucoup parler de ce qui ne fonctionne
pas mais maintenant vraiment l'objectif
c'est de se dire quelles solutions veut
mettre en place pour résoudre tous ces
problèmes que vous avez évoqué
collectivement voilà je crois que c'est
vous qui êtes désigné a battu les danois
je suis d'accord avec des étudiants dans
l'intitulé de la mesure il ya une
imprécision sur le mot végétalisation
si c'est juste pour mettre des arbres en
ville ou vraiment avoir une politique
ville nature pour toutes les langues y
creuser des pistes avec des personnes
d'horizons différents qui ne sont pas
des spécialistes est forcément synonyme
de débat il ya aide financière pour
qu'on soit précisée
on sera retoqué si on reste ça ne
passera pas sont dépassés spécial taux
d'inflation est tombé qui peut plus que
moi après la question d'après moi
faut-il qu'on de la convention non plus
coercitives fait un point d'ancrage et
c'est un point de débat au sein du
groupe
mais ça ne l'a commencée voilà
l'histoire mais comme c'est un point
d'inflexion animaux je ne veux pas
qu'ils discutent l'obligation et la
création je vais pas faire comprendre
que c'est une mesure importante
allô la planète convention vous allez
plus loin possible vous vous questionnez
c'est aussi une manière de tester
l'acceptabilité de nos mesures déjà
entre vous à la base on cherche pas à
créer du consensus
donc déjà en partant de ce principe là
on ne force rien on est à l'écouté
justement des principaux points de
divergence et c'est ça qu'on va creuser
c'est ça qu'on en fait qu on fait
travailler pour parvenir à ce qu'ils les
entendent ils les comprennent qu'ils se
les approprient et qu'ils aillent même
chercher les raisons de ces 10 ans us
les conditions pour faciliter
l'acceptation de cette mesure dans la
société par la société est en fait c'est
en gros quels sont les risques de refus
et du coup comment est ce qu'on ferait
pour pour s'assurer qu'est ce qu'on fait
pour s'assurer que ça fonctionne c'est
un peu la question de la justice sociale
ça peut être aussi la clé cette notion
de justice sociale est crucial avec la
difficulté de parvenir à construire des
mesures à la fois efficace susceptible
d'être acceptée par le plus grand nombre
soit
que jamais l'ambition déjà surendettés
soleil qui salit arrestations font ça
peut pas être la station zéro pour tout
le monde que les cas ne part mais on est
d'accord d'accord est allé lui contant
la voir est-ce que je mets acceptation
de par l'individu entre parenthèses
bien-être accompagnement personnel a dit
su rester bien leur nom je disais juste
que peut-être sur les matériaux
biosourcés doit avoir une chaussure
c'est que la noire appelée super sur le
rire super avec alain monte à sa merci à
toi aussi
[Musique]
nicolas 17 ans n'a pas beaucoup
participé aux marches pour le climat
mais il a dit oui à la convention sans
hésiter en se demandant quand même si
elle ne servirait pas de vitrine au
gouvernement
[Musique]
j'étais pas forcément le plus concerné
en intégrant un activiste engagé mais
j'en entendais parler puis on était
vraiment dans cette mouvance de greta
quoi du coup je suis bon bah beaucoup
quoi pourquoi pas et c'est ça va
peut-être me m'éclaircir sur les
problèmes environnementaux et puis si
j'ai la chance de pouvoir porter un
message en tant que je ne passait son
bac en même temps n'était pas du goût de
ses parents mais il a su les convaincre
et là où je me suis pris la claque c'est
quand j'ai vu l'urgence du problème
climatique chez les juments des pas
compte que c'était vraiment je me
rendais pas compte à quel point c'était
on était dans la musique la scierie dion
qui est dit est la convention que on
était tous climato-sceptiques sans
savoir vraiment parce que le choc
la vague d'informations de problème est
tellement importante
on a du mal à les assimiler tout neuf
alors à ton avis pourquoi le public
largement vous n'a pas accès à toutes
ces informations qui finalement sont
claires
quand on prend le temps de les expliquer
parce qu'à masquer gens parce que déjà
des gens sont intéressés mais c'est sur
foot
ils ont toujours ça m'intéressait parce
que finalement vous à personne quand on
était trois heures avant ces mâts des
gens qui étaient à la base
particulièrement concernée parce que tu
mènes honore toute la journée
et puis parce que tu utilises ont ils
ont réussi à nous sensibiliser à mort à
ses causes et puis quand le problème
mais il est compliqué de passes en six
minutes à ça ça va faire tache d'huile
parce que ils en parlent ils en parlent
énormément beaucoup beaucoup de cette
convention donc ses copains son
entourage je les pose la question donc
il ya un effet d de neige et ça je crois
que c'est une super bonne chose
vous rentrez s'il vous plaît
nicolas on a aussi beaucoup parlé avec
son professeur d'histoire qui a décidé
de dédier un cours à la convention
citoyenne
alors c'est une expérience démocratique
est nécessaire de comprendre en quoi
c'est une expérience démocratique en
terminale ils sont nombreux à ne pas
encore avoir voté qu'est ce que vous
pensez du fait qu'on ait finalement
sollicité 150 citoyens parmi lesquels
cinq jeunes auxquels on a dit rassemblez
vous réunissez vous réfléchissez fait
des propositions et on en tiendra compte
alors dites moi un petit peu vous y
croyez ou pas j'y crois ouais un peu
mais surtout on espère que ça va marcher
si on voit que la avec la convention
citoyenne si on voit que ça fonctionne
et qu'il ya un réel impact
forcément ça nous donnerait envie de
deux de participer plus justement
ben voila tu es un des acteurs de cette
démocratie participative
un point de vue là dessus le bus si tu
tirage au sort d'avoir pas en pl la
parole demain s'ils suent surveillants
et à côté j'ai un ingénieur mais la
parole d'ingénieurs sera pas plus
légitime que la mienne parce que il a un
métier qui est plus important que je
pense pas que c'est nous citoyens
on a vraiment un rôle ajoutant parce que
le bien qu'on puissent eux aussi
participer mais pas inquiet pour les
décisions n'est pas au courant de toutes
les lois qu'il faut faire que d'aller
concourir justement c'est pas du vent ce
qui dit le président du petit peu ça
mais après ça m'étonnerait qu'il y ait
vraiment des choix qui s'est passé on
s'aperçoit dans nos échanges quand on
est question d'y politiques reviennent
souvent la question de la légitimité des
politiques de cet écart même nos élèves
qui sont des lycéens nous nous renvoie
cela aussi est très souvent ça sert à
rien les politiques ne font ce qu'ils
veulent donc ça pose question ça doit
nous interroger
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
retour à la convention ou les 150
rencontres ce jour là des ong et des
entreprises
un speed dating pour nourrir leur
réflexion
cette confrontation entre société civile
et experts est une première pour
beaucoup d'entre eux
[Musique]
si vous cherchez la mesure
intelligente
à puce et au maximum c'est celle là une
solution existe
je suis totalement conscient conscience
mais la pression existe de son parcours
et de mosher l'occasion d'évaluer ce qui
se fait déjà pour voir comment aller
plus loin une sorte d'état des lieux qui
permettra d'aider à élaborer les mesures
les freins que vous connaissez déjà mais
qu'il ait répété williams s'est inscrit
pour rencontrer l'un des directeurs du
groupe bouygues ou démonter une fenêtre
d'un bâtiment et que vous souhaitez la
rejette dans un autre bâtiment c'est
interdit puisque dès lors qu'elle est
démonté ça devient automatiquement à
déchets déchets en france on a froid
novembre déchets j'ai décidé de dire oui
mais des glaces et se trouvaient tous et
que c'est vous qui nous font mais c'est
pourtant un particulier peut vendre sa
porte de garage
beaucoup ont ça fait une riz sur le bon
port bon ça c'est mauvais mais concrètes
et wiig et qu'on est le premier
démolisseur de france parce que vous ne
savez pas où x est premier démolition de
france entre nice et bien on n'était pas
bon de pousser beaucoup dans un corps
citoyens ont pu se forger des points de
vue encore plus complet sur les
objectifs
on a parlé en groupe comme on nous le
travail la convention peut aider à ce
que le matériaux biosourcés soit numéro
nous ont aussi donné des préconisations
ou des who
des points de blocage qu'ils rencontrent
et à nous aussi de pouvoir arriver à
trouver un moyen de l'heure
de pouvoir est-ce qu'ils puissent
avancer
bienvenue tiens barre juste derrière
vous pouvez prendre à boire avant tout
commence toujours bien d'un climat
terreau il ya un apéro donc il faut que
je vous senti à l'aise bonsoir
transformé en fervents défenseurs du
climat william organisé plusieurs
rencontres à nantes pour que son
expérience profite à tout le monde
c'est pour moi une aventure deux ans de
la convention citoyenne pour le climat à
chaque fois que je rentre à nantes de
paris je me dis ces mesures qu'on va
prendre quelle réalité elles vont avoir
dans nos quotidiens puisque le quotidien
c'est la véritable faire le territoire
proche c'est notre quotidien
il défend même la création d'une
convention citoyenne régionales
est-ce que tu as ressenti entre les gens
qui sont arrivés tels qu'ils étaient
dans leur vie et aujourd'hui les gens
avec qui tu travailles
est-ce que tu as ressenti des
changements est ce que tu aperçu des
choses est ce que tu peux me traduire ce
que tu as vécu le travail qui a été fait
de fonds de formation et sucre ou de
processus personnel sur le sur l'éveil
la transition écologique au final est
bluffant on a écouté des experts et on
est avec eux et on porte leur parole et
que après deux week-ends informations
que vous étiez un peu de choses près
tout sur la même longueur d'onde pas
forcément moi je trouve que d'avoir du
coup cette convention citoyenne où on
dit oui ça prend du temps et tout ça
mais c'est pas du temps perdu puisqu'il
ya 150 nouvelles chances maintenant de
pouvoir agir et de pouvoir essaie mais
la transition écologique voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aujourd'hui avec l'exercice que vous
avez fait hier on a six mesures vous
allez vers l'obligation complexe de
réflexion sur le financement c'est très
clair c'est clean
pour faciliter la reprise de leurs
travaux par le parlement où l'exécutif
la convention a tenu à se prononcer sur
des mécanismes de financement mais pas
une tva à taux zéro où on met pas de tva
mais à tout avait une taxe à taux zéro
ça n'existe pas donc là on est ridicule
on a exagéré peut certainement mais où
je suis moins d'accord avec toi brigitte
c'est que l'histoire de la tva taux zéro
pour ceux qui rénovent qui nous rappelle
les moyens pour l'état c'est vraiment
pas très grave
actuellement la tva c'est il ya tout va
pour l'état et c'est quand même une
grosse rentrée d'argent et on se
demandait si on vous prépare redirigée
cette rentrée d'argent peut-être faire
une tva verte ou aussi la faim l'a
redirigée quoi on va faire réagir clair
pour essayer de ces débats là avec
l'aide d'un groupe d'experts pour les
aider à passer de pistes de mesures à
l'élaboration de propositions de lois et
de règlements verte sur les produits bas
carbone c'est très bien mais votre
objectif est de que l'ensemble de
l'économie soit bas carbone à la fin
dans le parlement les députés n'ont pas
le droit de voter une loi qui dépensent
de l'argent sans dire comment on va le
financer
dans beaucoup des propositions que vous
faites on sent il ya un gros appel à des
dépenses
si l'ensemble de votre convention
propose quelque chose qui fait passer le
déficit de la france à 10%
le président il va mettre son veto et il
ne mettra pas au référendum et dire
attendez c'est juste pas possible je
peux pas couler le pays
non ces jeunes laissez moi finir laissez
moi finir c'est totalement faux c'est
inadmissible c'est anormal de nous
raconter ça dans notre proposition et
s'est pas fait mal digéré de l'expert
l'expert c'est pour nous aider à mieux
faire c'est comme si c'était nous qui
l'avons écrit sa vie
d'accord excusez moi c'est pas nous
quand la crise est une fille ça non
alors voilà on l'impression que quand on
parle de financement en se bride et donc
veulent pas se brider façon s'ils n'en
parle pas quelqu'un d'autre va le faire
cela même chose que ce qui avait été dit
si vous les mesures sont faites et
prêtes elles passeront si elles sont pas
prêtes
et quand on dit pas financer pas prête
et quelqu'un d'autre le fera pour revenu
c'est quelqu'un les mesures passeront
pas 100 kg et cet aspect financement qui
soit traitée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
ans
m
ce matériau
[Musique]
au cours des sessions chacun des groupes
se retrouvent en hémicycle pour débattre
avec l'ensemble des 150 membres de la
convention un premier test permettant de
voir comment sont perçus et les mesures
équipe que vous avez devant vous je sais
pas si vous les voyez ils ont patienté
entendus et écoutés réagi toute la
journée avec l'ensemble du groupe
ils sont ravis de vous présenter ce soir
leur mesure et leurs réflexions
pour répondre à notre objectif de
réduction de -40%
on doit taper fort vous allez voir que
c'est complexe coûteux dérangeant parce
que cela touche à nos logements et à nos
habitudes mais c'est indispensable
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous le groupe seloger propose
de contraindre les propriétaires à
rénover les passoires thermiques d'ici
nos mesures ne seront pas faciles à
mettre en place
c'est pourquoi nous voulons déployer sur
les territoires un réseau de guichet
unique s'est dit chez auront pour
mission d'informer et d'accompagner le
grand public dans la mise en oeuvre
d'une rénovation globale rendu
obligatoire par notre loi
leur objectif est de créer de l'emploi
tout en formant les professionnels du
bâtiment
je trouve que la formation c'est très
bien ça n'avait manque les ai par contre
j'ai un peu de mal à comprendre pourquoi
on ne formeraient reformeraient que 10%
fait des salariés on veut qu'ils
apprennent à travailler tous ensemble et
sur site alors peut-être que c'est passé
peut-être que tu as raison mais nous ça
voilà d'après ce que les experts ont dit
ça nous semble être le bon chiffre
et pour accompagner les plus démunis il
souhaite mettre en place un système d'
être progressif je te re proposait pour
les ménages très modestes et modeste la
gratuité c'est jamais bien d'accord on
pour toutes si on veut vraiment que ça
se passe et que ce soit vraiment un plan
qui va permettre d'aller au bout de de
l'ambition en obligé de rapprocher tout
le monde de cette rénovation
on l'a dit les gilets jaunes
nous arrive pas à faire les fins de mois
ils vont pas parler de logements donc
c'est extrêmement important de pouvoir
les rassurer de leur expliquer que c'est
leur intérêt ici l'intérêt pour nous
tous voilà voilà pourquoi on a besoin du
reste à charge 0 pour les plus modestes
il ya des choses aujourd'hui on sait pas
bien faire faire voler un avion sans
kérosène
pour le moment on ne sait pas bien faire
par contre isolé un bâtiment on sait
faire on a les moyens on a la technique
qu'est ce qui nous reste à trouver la
volonté la volonté politique on vous a
montré ce soir qu'on la rêve trouver de
l'argent visiblement des experts qu'on a
vu hier ils nous ont montré qu'ils
avaient de l'argent
donc on devrait pouvoir y arriver c'est
une opportunité extraordinaire il était
très méfiant de nous au début il pensait
qu'on allait les influences et il
pensait que on avait des sujets qu'on
voulait absolument on va faire passer
c'était le cas de la taxe carbone
notamment et se sont rendus compte
progressivement quand on n'était pas là
pour ça qu'en fait on était juste un
instrument au service de leur travail et
quand ils ont pris conscience de ça ils
sont partis
[Musique]
avec la crise du coc vide les travaux de
la convention se sont prolongées et tous
ont travaillé à distance
[Musique]
assistante d'éducation de 57 ans corinne
n'avait pas conscience de l'urgence
climatique avant d'être tiré au sort je
ne comprends pas pourquoi tous les
experts qu'on a entendu tout ce que nous
on entendu tout ce qui nous a fait
prendre conscience de cette urgence
climatique
tous ces experts sont passés déjà dans
les ministères et ma question c'est
pourquoi ça n'a pas été fait avant
oui je pense que c'est une question
courage politique elle regrette la
méfiance de certains élus à l'égard de
la convention et espère voir les
parlementaires se saisir de leur travail
et il faut pas que par le mental
subissent les lobbys des uns et des
autres c'est aussi le parlementaire qui
veut être et les lieux et qui veut faire
plaisir aussi à sa population pour voir
l'intérêt général avant son propre
intérêt j'ai mis tout mon coeur toute
mon énergie
tout ce qui me semblait être bon pour
tout le monde j'ai rien à perdre gg pas
plaire aux uns ou aux autres
[Musique]
ça va le maire de son village en vendée
la contacter quand elle a été tirée au
sort pour lui proposer de siéger à la
commission climat du conseil municipal
elle a mis du temps à accepter ce
pouvoir intégrer sein de la commission
et puis amené la richesse de ton
expérience pour pouvoir en train de le
traduire par des actions concrètes aussi
est-ce avec plaisir que je mettrai mon
expérience j'ai ainsi s'investir en
politique sans avoir été élu c'est une
façon pour elle de garder sa liberté
d'expression
c'est une cage de sort a fait que ça a
tout changé pour moi puisque c'est vrai
qu'au départ écologistes et attend que
j'aime pas beaucoup en définitive parce
que l'étiquette écologiste je trouve que
ça colle trop un parti politique est
pour moi l'écologie n'a pas de parti
politique
corinne est persuadé que le bulletin de
vote ne suffit plus pour se faire
entendre
la convention a sonné comme un déclic
public m'a sensibilisation ce que j'ai
vécu
oui c'est la mettre à profit pour
sensibiliser les autres personnes il ya
aussi eu jean jouzel qui a dit que la
bataille du réchauffement climatique se
gagnerait en gagnant la bataille de
l'opinion oui c'est important donc
lavent leur communiqué
[Musique]
je forme un sac
après neuf mois de travail les membres
de la convention reviennent aux cee pour
une dernière session
on y va vous êtes très dont nous allons
procéder au vote sur l'objectif sn1
rendre obligatoire la rénovation
énergétique globale des bâtiments 2040
je déclare le scrutin ouvert
répartis dans plusieurs salles ils ont
adopté la quasi-totalité de leurs
mesures à une large majorité
résultat du scrutin l'objectif est
adoptée à 87,3 pour cent
[Applaudissements]
oh
et le rapport final de la première
convention pour le climat est adoptée à
95 % pour williams
c'est la preuve qu'il est possible de se
mettre d'accord sur des sujets clivants
la forme du vote prendre des allures de
consensus pour le coup avec la formation
l'information qu'on a reçus au fur et à
mesure de pouvoir sortir ce que beaucoup
d'experts avant nous ce que beaucoup de
politiques avant nous ont essayé de
porter n'ont pas réussi à se faire
entendre
là on espère pouvoir être la voie pour
ces gens là on se sent vraiment utile à
quelque chose vous pouvez l'utilité de
conventions et de ce tirage au sort à
l'extérieur
certains dénoncent des mesures
liberticides trop radical j'ai repassé
un des gars qui sont m 7 la convention
il ya 2-3 mesure où ils incitent
mussolini chanteur faisait on assume le
fait d'aller très loin comme on disait
avec nicolas 2030 40 % des gaz à effet
de serre réduction de 40%
c'est dans dix ans on ne peut pas
s'amuser à faire des mesures elle
[Musique]
au lendemain de la vague écologiste du
second tour des municipales
emmanuel macron reçoit la convention à
l'elysée et annonce reprendre
l'essentiel de leurs propositions
en neuf mois la convention citoyenne a
renouvelé de manière inédite les formes
de la démocratie est bousculé le système
certaines mesures pourraient être soumis
à référendum
la plupart feront l'objet d'un projet de
loi mais le chef de l'état ne donnera ce
jour là pas plus de détails
j'ai besoin qu'au delà de ce travail de
conviction
vous soyez associez vous acceptez d'être
encore associé au travail de suivi avec
les administrations et avec les
parlementaires
[Applaudissements]
tous comptent bien faire jouer ce droit
d' alerte pour que leurs travaux ne soit
pas dénaturé sans concertation beaucoup
de gens pensaient que c'était un gadget
qu'on allait être entendu et ce soir
c'est l'action c'est pour ça que nous on
va être derrière et nous a demandé
d'être vigilants et que si quelque chose
n'allait pas fauteux l'interpellé donc
je pense qu'on attend au japon
pas question pour eux d'être les alibis
du virage vers des manuels macron
corinne nicolas et william sont
conscients que la tâche reste immense
[Musique]